in case you were under a rock or as the
case may be here in the northeast under
some snow
and you missed the blockbuster of all
blockbusters
the rams unloaded jared goff in his
contract
along with the third round pick in 2021
their first round picks in 2022 and 23.
mind you they couldn't trade their first
round pick at 21 because they don't have
it because they already got one
second yeah that's already gone it's
already spoken before
uh in exchange for matthew stafford
who wanted out of detroit detroit was
willing to oblige him
and he wanted to be an alien with sean
mcvay and he said yeah same here i mean
forget what you think you know about
matthew stafford
we're about to really see what this kid
is about he's not a kid at 32. well
we're about to really see what he's
about here's why i love the trade it
goes back to what i said to you a couple
of weeks back we were talking about i
forget which team you talk about we
always talking about
team construction and franchise mode
like this
this story is right up our alley but i
said to you
michael yeah driver standpoint yes
draft picks i told you this draft picks
are nothing
but food for the ego of general managers
and then along comes les sneed
who says what are draft picks other than
just like this money
the draft picks are like this money in
my pocket that like you know who says i
gotta spend it on unproven prospects
like why do i have to subscribe to the
conventional wisdom
of constructing my team through the
draft which we all acknowledge
is an inexact science and michael this
is coming from somebody who you know
my favorite sporting event of the year
is the draft i love the nfl draft
more than any other sporting event on
the calendar i live for the nfl draft
always have
okay why do i
says les sneed and by extension sean
mcveigh
have to like do things the way the rest
of y'all do it
and wait that kind of attitude right
there let me hope
further now further
when everybody's back what maybe 500
when it comes to first round picks
so who cares if about it still hey
listen
i can do what i want with these picks i
could spend it
on a better quarterback this is genius
the restaurant okay good luck detroit
good luck finding players
i just got your quarterback who you were
holding back
and i took i made you fools take on
jared goff and his contract
take my first round picks for the next
two years which
our next yeah the next two first round
picks forever
yeah they're fine fine and you know what
they will be at the end of the first
round too they're gonna be the end of
the first round
because we're going in the super bowl we
already got the best defense we
look at me i'm i'm in character right
now i'm a character right now
we're projecting we already got the
we got two hall of famers on defense
mike we're not wasting their primes
everybody else focuses on or we can't
waste this quarterback's prime no we got
aaron donald
who's the best player in the league and
the best looking player in the league
too yeah
okay and we got jaylen ramsey all we
need is a cory a quarterback away
from running the nfc west and the nfc
y'all could take our draft picks because
you know what
when you're on the clock at the end of
the first round detroit
we'll look up at our lombardi or
lombardi's as the case may be
because we just got the one missing
piece to our team so that's what
so michael now i'm back i'm michael
smith now i'm michael smith again that's
why i love that
that's why i love you out of your mind
hey you know the great thing about
franchise mode
great thing about franchise mode it's
like salary cap is just
it's a pigment the salary caps are
figment you look if you don't have
two nickels to rub together in franchise
mode well you can do some things
you can and they got to fix that little
loophole in the system you can like dump
off a high salary veteran
get a third round pick and now you're
back in business like i want to see
less less sneeze you get that
less need less picks uh less common
sense
two i want to see his portfolio they
this is ridiculous what the rams are
doing
you know one of my favorite movies
probably yours too i think i know you
well enough to know this
and we haven't even talked about it one
of my favorite movies is get out
you've seen get out oh it's great movie
great movie yeah so get out
uh at the point where chris is trying to
leave he figures out what's going on
he's like rose i don't know what to do
for mama the third time if i could
yeah well him we talk about him we talk
about the dad so chris
is trying to leave rose i need to keep
keith rose
those keys and as he's freaking out dad
is like
at the fireplace saying what is your
purpose
like excuse me what my purpose
is to get up on out of here get up out
of here right now
but i said that to the los angeles rams
what is your purpose is your purpose
to be entertaining but not to win
championships
they're entertaining jalen ramsey's
entertaining
aaron donald is dominant how'd that work
out
in the postseason did they lose in the
postseason because of jared goff no they
didn't
no they didn't they lost that great
they've been in the postseason like 12
other teams lost in the postseason that
what is that but you're talking about
their
quarterback away which is nonsense they
got rolled that great defense got
rolled by the packers the
divisional round they did yes they did
you can't
the reason the reason everybody else
maybe that game is
here's quarterback here's a tip here's a
tip
if you figured out something else and
nobody else has
either okay it's either or
it's very simple i'll make this binary
it's either or
you're either a genius or you're an
idiot
if you're doing something and nobody
else is doing it
you're either a genius or you're an
idiot
i'm not gonna call him an idiot but but
i'm not gonna call him a genius either
this is why people hold on to draft
picks michael because it is a
cheap way to build a roster you can get
great players
for cheap and cars you don't find
yourselves
currently find yourself in in a salary
cap situation
what's that what's the what's the ram
salary cap situation just absolutely
the piper eventually maybe they got a
different cap and everybody
but they're they're they're top heavy
and yes they gotta fill out their roster
with cheaper guys
michael it's currency it's currency you
can do
what you want with it you could not just
okay first of all
so wait you talk about something that
nobody's ever figured out before this
was fascinating
so i read this breakdown uh
raleigh uh mccaddy from the ringer
he had that the rams are the most
fascinating team building experience
experiment in the nfl he pointed out and
i didn't realize this
i did not realize this did you know so
uh the rams potentially will go unless
they trade back in
they will grow seven drafts without a
first round pick their last first round
pick was jared goff in 2016 right
they'll go seven drafts this isn't
unprecedented
the washington franchise from 1969 to
1979
went to georgetown drafts well i always
knew they were over
over the hill game because i remember
watching nfl films
the future is nice miami and and super
bowl seven
i didn't know why they were over the
hill game because he didn't like eating
one draft picks
can i just call him yeah pause for a
second
without even without googling without
going to pro football reference
i'm just going to ask you up top of your
head uh no they didn't win a
championship
i mean they ain't win nothing you came
home like that
i'm not done you can't win breaks hold
tight hang tight playboy
hang tight playboy 1984
to 1990. another franchise
went seven drafts without winning the
championship without excuse me without
executing a first round pick do you know
where that franchise was
that was also the washington football
franchise under joe gibbs
how many championships did they win in
that stretch they won a couple so they
went a couple okay
eight actually they were if you want and
no no no no but they won and you're a
fan
of time in your span they won one
actually they were understand they won
one
they they want 82 as matter of fact self
correct you said 84 tonight i totally
forgot
i know the other day we were talking
about the greatest super bowl teams of
all time i totally blanked on the fact
that the raiders beat the 83 washington
racists uh i forgot that they they they
were
all time highest scoring team but they
lost to the raiders anyway
i don't get sidetracked but then okay
joe gibbs dynasty three super bowls
three different quarterbacks 82
87 with doug williams 91 with mark
rippon though
that stretch they still win seven drafts
without a first round draft pick
i'm gonna give you all the same i give
it up but hold on wait a second wait a
second
you're missing a really big big point i
even though 84 to 90 10 i'm not going to
i'm not going to beat no salary accounts
no salary cap it's huge it's a salary
calculation it's a salary catholic and
it wasn't then
you can't you can't operate in a salary
like this
let me let me simplify it i'm not trying
to simplify it for you i'm simplifying
it for me
listen i'm taking the brass tack now i'm
gonna get down to brass tacks okay
did the rams make the playoffs last year
yes
yes did their quarterback who in
fairness had a busted thumb
that their quarterback did they make did
they get better at quarterback
with this i think so i think i think
what are we talking about here yeah then
what are we talking about
then what are we talking about they
upgraded they found a way michael
maybe it's because you want to talk
about projecting i did not believe
that there was any way in hell that they
can get a sucker
to take on jared goff's contract a
contract by the way
that the rams signed him to the rams
traded up to get jared off
signed him to an extension and fell out
of love with him
with the quickness i said
what's what your purpose my point
exactly
what but wait are they what they're
doing unloading jared goff
upgraded to matthew stafford prison guy
and and they went and and they had to
give up these picks to
upgrade and get rid of the contract like
what this is a lesson is there's always
a way out
and i give them props michael for not
sitting up here and saying well
i guess we're just gonna have to stick
it out with jared goff we don't like him
very much
but we like to stick it out with jared
goff and keep spinning our wheels
making the playoffs and knowing that we
got a ceiling meanwhile
oh look we got these first round picks
in 2022 and 23 to look forward to
no better this was being aggressive and
going for it
you know you know how to if you know how
to draft
you just the other day i'll tell you
what they're doing right now
and i'm gonna call after the show just
to make sure i'm lying i'm not gonna
call but
right now in baltimore eric decosta
and ozzie newsom are sick they're sick
listening to that like
what happened to michael smith he was
such a promising
uh bright i was about to hire him to be
my assistant general manager
taking my brother from another i was
about to hire a brother but now he
doesn't make any sense
he's telling us that the way we build
our team and that's why we have no
reason
what i'm saying no that's not what it
doesn't matter that's not what i'm
saying
that's no michael michael that's not
what i'm saying that's not what i'm
saying
not at all gosh no that's that's that's
blasphemous
no that's blasphemous i'm supposed to
get away talking about the los
angeles rams situation right i'm not
saying this is for everybody this is not
for everybody
but i'm saying you don't have to do
things the way everybody else does it
either
and if you're leslie and sean mcvay and
you're looking at your situation
and you look you look stuck like chuck
when they come to jared goff
you got him you signed him to a contract
that you shouldn't have
okay so what are you supposed to do just
sit there and just like be like all
right i guess we just got to deal with
it
but no instead they got creative
and you know what they had to pay a
person to pay a premium
to get somebody else to take him on and
they're better at the most important
position
it's a bottom line business you're right
michael how many championships
have they won i'll retort by saying this
how many were they gonna win with jared
goff
how many championships were they gonna
play with jericho they got you a super
name better than crypto when they got
the ship now or not
they got to a super bowl with jared goff
they got there with them they did and so
is he the same player
i i think so i mean he's hurt he got
hurt
he did play through a busted thumb what
am supposed to play
yeah you know and i would say this um
and we'll see what sean mcvay does
i would hope that sean mcvay would look
at matthew stafford a little differently
than he looked at
jared goff jared goff young player as
you said he traded up for him
you kind of kind of you have to walk
them through your offense to make sure
he's processing it
sometimes it takes some young
quarterbacks a little bit longer to
figure out all the things that are being
thrown at him and
sean mcvay is that kind of a voice in
your head i hope he doesn't try that
approach
matthew stafford that's annoying i just
imagine it's annoying and
it's not conducive to getting the best
out of your quarterback i'm going to
predict here it is i'm going to throw it
out there
i'm going to predict that jared goff has
a really good season
in detroit i think he is better off look
it helped him being with sean mcvay
who was a bright offensive mind i think
it hurt him
year after year to have mcveigh in his
ear all the time
yeah i i didn't know just let me
let me just go out and play my game i i
just don't know
how do you know he's capable of doing
that i don't know he's capable of doing
that maybe mcveigh
and how does sean mcvay know it you at
some point you got to trust it
what at some point you gotta try such a
fascinating trade we'll find out about
everybody we'll find out if stafford is
as underrated as we all think he is
i think you agree with that right that
stafford is underrated under appreciated
but he just wasn't able to
you know transcend the circumstances but
really good quarterback
so we'll find out about stafford not
he's in a better situation presumably
we'll find out if if
uh mcveigh was being held back by
jericho or like you just said
if jared goff was being held back by
sean mcveigh which i tend to doubt i'm
rooting for jericho
seems like a nice guy by all accounts
and hope he does have a good season
but going back to your point about you
trying to you so you try to make me
like speak against the ravens but you
know i don't do that okay
i don't appreciate that but everybody or
a lot of people
no not a lot of teams because michael
wouldn't you acknowledge by and large
people it's it's people hit swinging
this on the draft especially in the
first round
like there are no guarantees well not
especially like this but
i thought we had this conversation no
especially in the first round
yeah we're going here again don't be
going here again we are definitely going
here again
because of the when i say especially i'm
not talking about necessarily the number
of people going in the hall of fame but
when you want to talk about
bus when you're in the first round
that's where that's where the bus label
comes from when somebody's taking you in
the first round
and you end up just being a guy or not
even making the team or
hanging around for long or signing
another a second contract then you
missed on that first round pick
what i'm simply saying is michael yes
the ravens have nailed the draft but
okay let's go to let's go to your
backyard hell in my backyard for that
matter
how the patriots been doing their draft
lately how's that working out for him
wasn't a big story this year about
belichick's drafts
as of late the greatest right coach of
all time oh
so the rams did what they needed to do
to get better
simple and plain full stop they're
better today than they were on friday
period that's why i love the trade i i i
just can't wait
i can't wait until um
my goddaughter your daughter savannah
says to you in a couple years as you try
to have this conversation with her about
hey you don't want to go she already
knows this
but you'll probably say it anyway you
don't want to go and spend all your
money right now
you know you want to put some away you
don't want to spend it right now hey
why not dad right now right now this is
in front of me right now
i can get better right now what do you
mean for tomorrow
save for tomorrow i saw you on brother
from another saying
go for it right now hello come on
i love it but michael there's a balance
okay you want to take it there
you want to take it there let's take it
there there's a balance michael because
you know what you can't do
you can't take it with you see you're
talking to the wrong one
i'm the spender in my household talk to
my wife about that i'm the spender
i don't care i don't care about money i
shouldn't be i shouldn't be saying this
i shouldn't be saying in front of people
i don't care about
it you can't take it with you
so yes there you have the you don't
think about something you got a device
put it away you got a great light on
your ankle and sarah knows everywhere
you go
no i just don't even know the passwords
though i don't know i can't access it
you wanna hear something crazy the other
day saturday
saturday i was at the bank trying to
wire money
my way and she knew about it my wife
knew about it wasn't nothing sneaky i
was at the bank trying to wire money
you know what the woman told me she was
like um uh-oh
we don't have your signature on file and
i'm looking through your checks
it's like there's no signature for you i
was like i don't write any checks i
don't sign anything my wife signs it
so we had to call my wife get her off
the peloton
and get her to come to the bank so that
she
could sign the paper for me she had to
actually come to the bank
she had to come to the bank because you
can authorize it even though my name is
on it
we can't face no missing they can't fail
in person and she had to sign it they
went back months it was like when the
last time you ordered a check i'm like i
don't remember
point being i don't know how we got on
this all i'm saying is
if you're the rams tomorrow doesn't
matter especially if you put a lombardi
in the lobby of soulfire stadium
tomorrow just don't feel like that i
don't know we'll figure out how long i'm
going to create it there
live and i guess we just promise
yeah okay thank you preacher uh you're
welcome
i think we disagree on on who they are
too
and i think that's where it's coming
from you think the rams are a
quarterback away from
greatness and i don't i think they think
they're a quarterback away
i think they're the number one defense i
think they got good wide receivers i
think they found a good young running
back in cam makers i think they got a
really smart coach
so what's missing what's come on michael
like don't we don't disagree on this
what's the one
thing that that you look at with the
rams you know that made you not trust
the rams come on now
like they were gonna go into they were
gonna have a competition between jared
goff and john wilford
or wofford i don't know how you say his
name call it like you know that was a
that's that's the one thing you look at
that roster and you don't like how can
you
they had a little more defense in the
league last year they got aaron donald
and jaylen ramsey
now you add matthew stafford to that but
number one defense in the league okay
great you know last year
the number one defense in the league for
two consecutive years
has been bounced from the playoffs in
the same round
and two consecutives for two years in a
row no i'm saying it's between
last year was it was last year was the
patriots number one defense
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry and for
two consecutive years
that number one defense in the league
you know gets bounced out of playoffs i
think they're uh
i think they're an interesting team i
think they're going to be far less
interesting
when they try to build and their players
get old at the same time
and they're not able to refresh with
elite talent not they better hey listen
this is what les needs seriously
that no less a little bit
he's gonna what he's gonna have to do
now he's put the pressure on himself
most general managers don't get a chance
to make two trades like this because the
first trade
for jared goff and he turns out to be a
bus then you're out
you trade up for the number one pick in
a draft you give up all the stuff and he
doesn't work out and you got to move on
from him
and you run into cap jail which they did
before a couple years ago and had to cut
their players and you know cutting guys
because they had the salary cap problems
same thing
you do this again now the pressure is on
you
you better hit those few picks that you
have
you better do it right they just worked
look and they first by the way that's
the other part of it it ain't just first
one of my favorite uh websites is uh pro
sports transactions
like go look at their draft capital so
in this year's draft they have a second
a sixth and a seventh that's what
happened this year's trap
as of right now and and next year's
draft
i'm a second a third a fifth
a six and a seventh in next year's draft
and in 23
they have they just earned their first
round pick at this point um
so i mean it's look you're right michael
this bill is going to come dude this
bill's going to come dude
and they're doing it yo look in the
meantime yolo what's up 30.
if you i'm 32-33
32 and his best days are ahead of him
his ladder will be greater
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 pm eastern time on peacock
appreciate you